[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique sur tv fil 78 et invité
aujourd'hui françois simeoni le
secrétaire départemental du front
national sa candidate est elle d'ores et
déjà assuré de figurer au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle oui si l'on en
croit les sondages de ces derniers mois
pas seulement pour l'emporter en mai il
faudra fédérer l'ensemble des électeurs
comment le fn va-t-il s'y prendre c'est
ce que nous verrons et puis au cours de
ce rendez-vous nous vous ferons aussi le
point sur les campagnes dans les
yvelines du parti socialiste de lutte
ouvrière ou encore de l'union populaire
républicaine dont jean-françois simeoni
responsable du front national dans le
département des yvelines conseiller
municipal d'opposition à versailles au
civil vous êtes enseignant et vous avez
j'imagine suivi avec attention le
premier à des débats de cette campagne
présidentielle avec les cinq principaux
candidats vous en avez pensé quoi
bien sûr je pense qu'on était hier soir
très nombreux postes de télévision j'ai
trouvé que ce débat finalement déjà posé
problème de ne par le fait qu'il n'y
avait qu'une seule partie des candidats
qui s'intéressent candidats ont eu leur
parrainage donc c'est je comprends très
bien là la réaction de nicolas
dupont-aignan sur tf1 chaud que c'est un
petit peu normal je me rappelle une
époque où les candidats présentés là
programmes et des séquences vidéo et que
le débat n'avait lieu qu'au deuxième
tour
donc je pense que cela il ya un petit
problème de démocratie ce niveau là
puisqu'à priori un candidat qui a ses
parrainages est un candidat comme les
autres alors après pour les règles du
csa vous les connaissez ce sont celles
de l'équité dans un premier temps
l'égalité seulement à partir du 9 avril
et le conseil constitutionnel a tranché
sur la démarche le de tf1 pour revenir
sur le débat en lui même sur la façon
dont on s'est comporté marine le pen à
l'oralité pertinente convaincante
je pense que notre candidate a été bien
sûr convaincante
j'ai trouvé les autres candidats
notamment peut-être macron le moins
expérimenté pas très convaincant j'ai
trouvé aussi monsieur fillon un petit
peu éteint le débat je pense n'a pas
véritablement n'a pas pu convaincre à
mon avis les électeurs je pense que
beaucoup de gens ont dû rester sur leur
faim et il y aura d'autres débats
puisque cinq candidats on le rappeler
ont participé à ce tout premier débat
qui est aussi une première sous la vème
république il y en aura deux autres le 4
avril le 20 avril et cette fois ci les
onze candidats vont y participer de
marine le pen à emmanuel macron de
françois fillon à benoît hamon également
ou encore de jean luc mélenchon à
nicolas dupont aignan en passant par
nathalie arthaud françois asselineau
mais aussi des est qualifié de dernière
minute qui ont réuni les 500 parrainages
sur le fil je pense à jacques cheminade
philippe poutou ou encore jean lassalle
françois simeoni peut-être votre regard
sur les différentes candidatures est ce
qu'on est là sur une diversité qui est
représentative je pense notamment marine
le pen qui avait apporté son parrainage
à henri guaino aurait guaino est député
des yvelines qui finalement lui ne peut
pas participer au scrutin
oui la diversité écoutez on est déjà
confronté à une difficulté c'est
l'obtention des parrainages
ce système d'obtenir 500 parrainages
d'élus est un héros peut dans une
certaine difficulté pour les candidats
qui sont qui ne sont pas très connus il
faut savoir actuellement que les mères
avec
l'obligation de 2 pour les communes de
rentrer dans les communautés
d'agglomérations sont comme beaucoup
plus astreints à des difficultés d'ordre
économique liés par exemple au
financement des communes à l'opt
l'obtention de subventions de la part
des communautés d'agglomération de la
part des départements
donc certains maires auront des
difficultés qu'ils nous ont d'ailleurs
communiqué 1 a donné le parrainage comme
servir que la règle n'est pas bonne et
que ça limite le débat démocratique
écoutez on ne peut pas se présenter à
écouter effectivement il ya c'est en
plus cette année il y avait une
procédure qui a été un petit peu modifié
qu'une parution immédiate des
applications sur le parrainage c'est une
difficulté dès que nous nous avons
participé activement à la recherche de
parrainages sur les yvelines et ongles
nous avons eu un assez bon retour de
denner contact et on a contacté à peu
près là l'ensemble oui les cent quarante
et une communes de moins de 1500
habitants en quasi totalité et on a tous
souvent eu un bon contact avec les
maires mais par contre nous on dit
qu'effectivement s'il souhaitait pas par
elie c'est justement pour ce problème
lié au financement tension de
subventions alors parlons des
parrainages justement dans les yvelines
le soutien des élus dans les yvelines
ils sont 4 143 sur 300 à s'être prononcé
le parrainage n'est pas obligatoire je
le rappelle c'est françois fillon qui
reçoit le plus grand nombre de
signatures 81,18 les juppéiste les
sarkozystes lui dit encore le parti
chrétien démocrate ont mis de côté les
différends et les désaccords des
dernières semaines
on peut citer les noms de valérie
pécresse gérard larcher pierre bédier ou
encore michel laugier le président de
saint quentin en yvelines qui ont
parrainé françois fillon écouter aussi
le maire divers droite de coignières lui
aussi accordé à son parrainage à
l'ancien premier ministre
c'est le programme qu'il nous faut
actuellement 1 pour relever la france
pour lui redonner un nouvel élan et donc
je n'ai pas eu de doute
bien sûr bien sûr ce sont des moments
difficiles mais je n'ai pas eu de doutes
en termes de parrainage c'est ensuite
benoît hamon député des yvelines qui
arrive en deuxième position douze
signatures parmi lesquelles le maire de
magny les hameaux ou encore la première
secrétaire du ps dans les yvelines
ecoutez-le il propose
un chemin une voix c'est pas un homme
providentiel c'est un chemin qu'il
propose à la france pour
un avenir l'avenir de nos enfants des
petits-enfants des futures générations
dans une société qui soit une société
sociale qui soit une société écologique
et qui soit aussi un renouveau
démocratique je me retrouve dans ses
idées dans son programme
j'ai confiance dans aussi dans l'homme
qui est je pense que tout ça mis bout à
bout justifie largement ses parrainages
on remarquera tout de même que certains
élus poids lourds donc département dont
catherine tasca la sénatrice ps des
yvelines soutien de manuel valls pendant
la primaire n'a pas accordé de
parrainage même chose d'ailleurs pour le
maire de trappes guy malandain trappe où
siégeait en tant qu'élu municipal benoît
hamon pourtant parmi les autres
parrainage notable ils sont neuf à avoir
corps dès leur signature à emmanuel
macron le maire divers gauche des
mureaux ou encore le président du modem
des yvelines conseiller régional bruno
myle yens jean luc mélenchon lui a
séduit seulement deux élus dont nelly
duthu la mère de la verrière et on va
parler du cas de marine le pen justin un
mot de parrainage peut être plus
surprenant est la mère eut des ide
voisins le bretonneux qui s'est en effet
portée qui a en effet porté son choix
sur l'écrivain alexandre jardin qui m'a
frappé c'est lui en tout cas j'ai
surtout connu sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui m'a frappé c'est lutte est le bon
sens de son discours et du tri c'est une
valeur qui m'est cher pour que les
gagner les élections municipales
justement sur le terrain du bon sens il
parle de la viande
et c'est m6 le thème de lait de mai
dernière de mai dernier veut et je
trouve que il y tient le coup vraiment
positif qui parle même de révolte
positives en direction des plus
tendances moquer de moi même des gens de
mon propre camp bonbons ils font comme
ils veulent et c'est une réaction comme
une autre moi je vois là je me moque de
personne pour quelqu'un d'autre son
parrainage à le respecte ce qu'il fait
n'est pas grave
françois simeoni marine le pen dans les
yvelines a reçu 2 parrainage le maire de
mantes la ville la conseil régional
yasmine belmadi aussi c'est peu
finalement
mais voilà comme je vous l'expliqué nous
avons reçu les parrainages
nos élus alors il est clair que les
candidats qui sont et qui sont soutenues
par un appareil politique avec beaucoup
d'élus comme notamment l air dans l'est
dans les yvelines obtiennent leur
parrainage facilement mais encore une
fois il est évident que lorsqu'on
téléphone et qu'on essaye d'obtenir ce
parrainage d'abord il faut préciser que
le parrainer quinquin ce n'est pas être
en accord avec ses idées c'est lui
permettre à madame participer au jeu
démocratique
donc c'est assez déjà une étape que
l'explication qu'il faut qu'il faut
franchir et ensuite il est clair que
beaucoup beaucoup de mères au vent ont
posé ce problème lié au financement et
sa salle et tiens on sait très bien qu'à
une réduction drastique de l'est de
participation de l'état aux communes et
donc si on coupe en plus ces subventions
du département et déco et des
communautés d'agglomération
je comprends la difficulté de la gestion
des mairies
donc ça c'est une différence qui m'amène
justement à me poser des questions sur
l'obtention par certains candidats que
deux des 500 parrainages
voilà qu'ils obtiennent finalement à
certains assez facilement vu le main que
on a par exemple au jeu je citerai pas
de noms mais bon je pense que ces noms
viennent facilement à l'esprit de
personne qui ne sont pas soutenues par
des structures qui n'ont pas d'élus qui
obtiennent jacques cheminade
oui vous avez d'ailleurs soit aussi du
conseil constitutionnel la répartition
en termes de d'élus des deux c'est qu'un
de ses parrainages
il est intéressant de voir par exemple
que certains
vont avoir pour les mets françois fillon
les parrainages des élus aient l'air
donc c'est principalement leurs
parrainages
les socialistes qui sont élus par les
fins sont parrainés par les spécialistes
nous sommes les élus nous sommes
parrainés par les élus du front national
et sur certaines candidatures comme ça
que vous mentionnez c'est principalement
code du mariage des délais rossi
également demain on va parler justement
peut-être de certains certains de ses
candidats je pense notamment à l'upm qui
sont finalement des concurrents sur
certaines de vos propositions la sortie
de l'euro de l'europe même par exemple
on va écouter le représentant de l'ue p
r dans les yvelines le représentant de
françois asselineau il était récemment
sur notre plateau écouter l'europe c'est
la paix ça c'est un slogan que j'entends
que depuis que je suis tout petit au
sein de l'ordre
oui au sein de l'europe ça dépend est-ce
que l'ukraine vers l'europe par exemple
le crâne et dans le continent européen
et je n'ai pas vraiment l'impression que
le le climat soit un climat pacifique du
contenu craint actuellement le crime
n'est pas au sein de l'union européenne
et 71 voix pour ça qu'elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui on peut aussi faire le même
raisonnement
wii passe encore mais moi ça me fait
penser à un épisode des simpson où il y
avait un ours qui s'était échappé d'un
zoo il ya au maire qui fait toute une
série de patrouille pour empêcher les
ours de venir et puis dialyse à regarde
ça marche volatilise à lui 10e ce que tu
dis est fallacieux au maire lui répond
merci et
les années c'est de lui faire comprendre
qu'aucun lien de cause à effet c'est à
peu près la même chose pour l'union
européenne
en fait je pense que d'une part on
inverse la cause et la conséquence c'est
plutôt la paix qu'a fait l'union
européenne que l' inverse et nous nous
pensons à lui br que l'union européenne
risque de nous entraîner vers la guerre
à des conflits notamment avec la russie
ou avec le monde arabo musulman
françois simeoni votre regard sur l'upm
et sur le programme de l'upm sur cette
sortie de l'europe justement est ce que
ça vous fait concurrence sur les
propositions de la sortie de l'euro la
sortie de l'europe car tout d'abord
monsieur asselineau est un excellent
conférencier et son thème effectivement
c'est essentiellement basée sur la
réaction devrait avoir les européens
face aux états unis pour lui
effectivement la création de l'union
européenne et elle y est issu donc des
états unis pour affaiblir l'europe donc
sinon je suis qu'un assez étonné et bien
évidemment c'est nous une 1.2 importe
quoi souveraineté nationale mais ceci
dit attention et un travail sémantique
qui est important c'est que il ne s'agit
pas de sortir de l'europe serait bien
capable de sortir de l'europe on est lié
de manière éternelle au continent
européen donc il s'agit absolument pas
de sortir de l'europe
il s'agit juste de de voir comment on
pourrait renégocier les traités liant la
france à l'union européenne le traité
qui ont été vous le savez où la vie des
français a été complètement déconsidéré
en 2005 puisque traité de lisbonne et a
été ensuite obtenu sans l'accord
finalement des des électeurs français
donc cette cette remise en cause donc
d'être était une union européenne dans
le programme de marine mind se donne six
mois donc s'il est élu pour renégocier
avec nos partenaires européens
les traités de l'union va définitivement
comme le souhaite françois salino par
exemple c'est ça qui vous différencie
nouvelle en moins loin et d'ailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs une des critiques qu'il
fait à notre égard puisqu'il est très
très hostile comme et au front national
françois asselineau j'ai pu l'entendre
j'ai pu le voir au fait aussi pas du
moins ses militants sur les marchés où
ils prétendent justement être les seuls
à vouloir sortir de cette union
européenne ce qui est quand même on
n'avait pas peur qu'ils vous prennent
quelques voies au passage alors très
rapidement pourquoi on n'a aucune
crainte là dessus parce que je pense que
ce n'est pas à nous qu'il veut ce que ce
qui nous va prendre des bases plus du
côté de fillon et de macron on va sortir
on va qui restait sur cette question
européenne mais on va évoquer maintenant
la la sortie de l'euro le retour au
franc avec notre rubrique vous en avez
un habitude légal checking à présent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
site internet fondé par des membres de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui vérifie les fondements
juridiques et des propositions des
candidats nous regardons régulièrement
elle certains points du programme cela
s'appelle du légal checking bonjour
nicolas bon jour d'aujourd'hui il est
question de la sortie de l'euro oui
alors début tous déjà parent par un
constat établi et que personne ne
conteste si l'on revient en offrant la
valeur de la nouvelle monnaie nationale
sera forcément inférieur à l'euro actuel
même le front national le dis on estime
d'ailleurs que le nouveau franc aurait
une valeur inférieure à 20% à l'euro
d'aujourd'hui
conséquence de cela et qui inquiète
beaucoup d'économistes et les opposants
de marine le pen
le coût de la dette publique supérieure
actuellement à 2000 milliards d'euros
elle exploserait alors selon eux
petite explication actuellement deux
tiers de cette dette est détenue par des
fonds ou aux investisseurs étrangers est
des créanciers qui ont investi dans
notre dette en euro et qu'il faudrait
donc rembourser dans la même monnaie or
je vous le disais l'euro nous coûtera
plus cher avec un nouveau franc dévalué
la dette à rembourser sera donc plus
lourde c'est un mécanisme économique
assez banal finalement
le front national dit que ce ne sera pas
le cas finalement que le scénario de
l'explosion de la dette est exagéré oui
justement alors l'argument avancé par
leur front national depuis maintenant
quelques années c'est celui de la loi
monétaire aussi appelé la lex moneta et
qui autorise concrètement les états à
rembourser par leurs nouvelles monnaies
la dette émise via des contrats qui sont
de son droit
or 97 % de la dette française est sous
contrat français du coup pas d'explosion
de la dette selon le fn l'argument est
valable d'ailleurs mais difficile à
utiliser pour autant écouter vincent
couronne fondateur du site internet les
surligneurs c'est une règle ancienne dur
internationale qui date en fait de 1929
et qui veut que on peut neutraliser les
effets de cette perte de
de propriété en assurant la parité entre
l'euro et la nouvelle monnaie nationale
le problème ça c'est que cet argument là
du front national ne passe pas parce que
cette règle c'est du droit international
or dans la plupart des états la
protection de la propriété à un rang
constitutionnel et le droit
international et infra constitutionnel
donc les juges danser et à la flore ont
toujours pris mes a priori le droit de
propriété des détenteurs de dettes et
pas alex mon état et est donc cette l'ex
mon état est invoquée par le front
national n'aura pas d'effet et donc
concrètement où wilfrid silo quittent
l'euro pour une nouvelle monnaie
nationale cela aura forcément un coup
malgré l'argument une nouvelle fois
valable du front national et même dans
le cas où de longues et nombreuses
batailles judiciaires sont lancés
france s'assignent année voilà vous
l'avez vous exprimer on a d'ailleurs vu
là et tous entendu la remarque de
françois fillon hier soir sur l'euro
c'est une démarche qui consiste en fait
à faire peur aux français en leur disant
tout simplement votre épargne va être
anéantie
en cas de retour aux monnaies nationales
avec qu'en passant une dévaluation déjà
deux termes de dévaluation est un
terreau qui est inappropriée puisque la
dévaluation supposerait qu'il existe
encore un échantillon un étalon
monétaire ce qui n'est plus le cas donc
on ne peut parler que de dépréciation de
la monnaie par rapport à une autre
monnaie ça peut être par rapport à
l'euro existence a peut être par rapport
au dollar après le nouveau franc serait
forcément inférieur à l'europe peut elle
sa soeur ça c'est sûr c'est avéré
estimant donc le nook en recul sur avec
nos économistes sur la dépréciation de
la nouvelle monnaie par rapport à l'euro
donc serait de l'ordre de 20%
il est très important de voir que quand
on présente les choses comme ça vous
fait peur aux français lors des français
imaginent qu'ils vont perdre un procès
n'aurait pas à moi je l'expliqué très
simplement que en janvier 2015
l'euro a perdu 20% de sa valeur par
rapport au franc suisse et par rapport
au dollar et je demande aux français ce
qu'ils ont perdu 20% de leur épargne
absolument pas les français ne sont
absolument pas rendu compte
il faut voir que cette dépréciation
monétaire
elle a des effets alors les effets sont
toujours présentés comme les sept plaies
d'égypte déjà effet sur les pas des
français vous allez perdre votre vos
sous donc ça clairement expliqué voilà
il s'est produit en janvier 2015
et vous avez vu aucune conséquence de
cette de cette dépréciation de la
monnaie
la débauche d'argent la dette publique
alors nous parlons maintenant des
conséquences financières par beaucoup
d'investisseurs étrangers les deux tiers
du fait des congés de faire comme lors
des débats de vous dire d'être concis
clair rapide sujet difficile très
difficile parce que justement sur 7 sur
ce débat il faut il faut expliquer les
conséquences de la dépréciation d'une
monnaie sont de deux ordres
une conséquence économique les
conséquences financières sur les
conséquences financières
la dette la dette publique comme vous
disiez la dette publique de 2200
milliards détenus a à peu près
67 % par des investisseurs étrangers
c'est comme vous l'avez dit cette dette
est libellée en droit français à 97%
ce qui veut dire que en droit étranger
sur les 3% restants nous avons nous
allons à subir des effets de la
dépréciation 3% de 2000 milliards ça
fait 60 milliards une dépréciation de 20
% de 60 milliards ça fait si je calcul
bien 12 milliards donc le surcoût de la
dette sorti de suite en fête en fête le
hic c'est se dire est ce que les
investisseurs étrangers vont accepter
d'être payés avec le nouveau front qui
aura moins de valeur c'est juste ça le
problème souligné par les surligneurs
après peut-être qu'ils le feront mais ça
veut dire que si vous voulez il ya une
même à prédire de l'avenir et on a du
mal à penser qu'un investisseur étranger
va vouloir perdre de l'argent il a pu il
n'aura pas vraiment le choix
le contrat de prêt de freins et de libé
ni on se rendre aux français c'est parce
que tous les pays
j'ai par exemple le cas de la drees le
cas de la grèce 36% en droit local et
64% ont droit étranger alors évidemment
vont un gros problème la france et 90 et
pour 3 3% les investisseurs vont
continuer à venir ils n'auront pas de
choix et pour les français il n'y aura
pas d'incidence sur le portefeuille
aucune incidence sur les pannes sur la
sur la dette publique donc comme on l'a
expliqué une incidence de 12 milliards
quand on compare cela aux chiffres un
jeu que l'on a pu faire sur le coût de
l'immigration par exemple 70 milliards
c'est complètement négligeable
je rappelle que le déficit public
actuellement de l'ordre de 84 milliards
donc cet effet catastrophique présenter
enfin présenté comme étant
catastrophique n'a pas lieu d'être et
par contre les conséquences économiques
de la sortie de l'euro parce qu'il ya
aussi des conséquences économiques on
peut on peut en parler c'est ce qui rend
l'intérêt de la de la dépréciation de la
monnaie comme ça se faisait toujours
avant qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
nous avons en france reste 30 secondes
voire sur cette thématique là perdu de
la compétitivité comme effectivement le
graff qui a présenté cette élection
depuis la création de l'euro voilà
'l'indice de production industrielle
pour la france a chuté pour l'allemagne
mène ça s'adresse à augmenter ça
pourrait donc vous avez manifestement le
problème de l'euro qui est un problème
très européen qui nous a fait perdre à
peu près 30 points de compétitivité par
rapport à l'allemagne c'est pas le seul
point mais c'est une des raisons
merci nicolas on vous retrouve lors de
la prochaine édition du 7 8 politique et
avec toujours un partenariat avec les
surligneurs pour passer en revue
quelques points de programmes des
différents candidats à la présidentielle
un mort françois simeoni tout de même on
parle tout de même souvent du plafond de
verre pour le front national barrière
infranchissable qu'il empêchera
d'accéder au pouvoir est ce que vous y
croyez toujours vous vous dites que
marine le pen va dépasser les 22 % dans
les yvelines elle était à 12,4 en 2012
alors dans les yvelines qui est un
département un petit peu difficile quand
même que le financier s'est
historiquement avec des secteurs
favorisés donc et la crainte de sète
notamment de cette sortie de l'euro ce
département évolue déjà positivement
depuis pour le front national depuis
déjà pas mal d'années puisqu'on est
passé de 8 8% régionales 2010 à 20% au
départemental
donc cette évolution et vous mentionnez
effectivement les 12 8% qu'on a vu que
marine a remporté aux élections
présidentielles de 2012
cette évolution ici va se faire je pense
qu'on a
un potentiel qui peut nous permettre si
on en croit une progression linéaire de
prévoir sur les yvelines un chiffre de
l'ordre de 22%
nous allons passer maintenant à notre
dernière séquence de cette émission la
présidentielle vu par
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la campagne vu par les électeurs parce
qu'ils se vont se prononcer dans
l'isoloir une profession une catégorie
socioprofessionnelle aujourd'hui une
petite entorse à cette règle nous sommes
allés tout simplement sur le marché de
trappes écouter les électeurs clients
vendeurs voici les sujets de discussion
actuellement 65 ans avait deux ans sans
emploi qui possible j'ai fait plus de
100 demandes mais rien d eau
il faut penser aux seniors qui est moins
de moins de chômage
ce que je souhaiterais aussi même si je
suis assistante sociale je ne suis pas
pour l'assistanat et du coup je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des minima
sociaux mais qui n'est pas trop non plus
et qui est du contrôle
on met des casseroles partout
sincèrement c'est pas une bonne campagne
toi je trouve
de beau temps
j'ai remarqué c'est chaque fois que les
élections se rapproche je veux dire les
politiques ils commencent à parler de
nous ont dit les trois zip l'immigration
les
l'insécurité et l'islamisme quoi si pour
faire peur aux gens et voilà c'est en
général c'est que que je dis pas que
c'est tout est faux mais je veux dire 80
% c'est faux il parle jamais des vrais
problèmes des gens et la plupart des
vrais problèmes c'est le pouvoir d'achat
c'est le travail c'est tout ce à quoi
les gens maintenant
au lieu d'acheter un kilo par siens kg
par là il vient il se contente d'une
pièce parce que ce par là et il ya même
des gens qui viennent
je veux dire qui vient la fin de marché
pour pour avoir je veux dire de la
marchandise un peu moins cher françois
simeoni peut-être votre réaction vous
allez aussi un sur les marchés pour
distribuer les tracts voulait rencontrer
tous ces électeurs lorsque vous entendez
par exemple qu'on fait peur aux gens les
trois i l'insécurité et l'immigration
tout ça c'est pour faire peur aux gens
vous leur dites quoi moi je leur dit que
effectivement sur l'insécurité et les
dangers islamistes c'est une réalité
maintenant je pense qu'effectivement on
a volé aux français une partie
importante de la campagne parce que leur
préoccupation principale c'est l'emploi
c'est le pouvoir d'achat est
effectivement c'est une chênaie
uniquement qu'avec un changement radical
et l'établissement d'un véritable
patriotisme économique qu'on pourrait
arriver à trouver les solutions
moi ce que je souhaite peut dire c'est
ceux qui se posent des questions ils
pourraient consulter donc les 144
proposition qui le site sur le site
marine 2017 avec également un dossier
très documenté sur l'euro pour que les
gens puissent se faire une idée le par
eux mêmes et les candidats ont
maintenant un peu moins à peu près un
mois pour pour vous convaincre juste moi
d'aller voter pour eux pour cette
élection présidentielle les 7-8
politique reviendrons bien évidemment
sur cette campagne dans le département
nous différentes éditions du journal
également merci françois simeoni d'avoir
été est notre invité ici alors du
prochain numéro je recevrai lutte
ouvrière pour évoquer la campagne très
bonne soirée sûreté des fils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]